hi everyone welcome to another awesome
language design review this is part of
our language completeness and
consistency series
and we have a number of topics
first up
this is a horrifying one a round and Min
and numerical order
right okay so we think we've untangled
that this at least the symmetric case
and
um
right the the question it was you know
when
out had you know how do we sort these
etc etc and sort of one of the issues is
you know since these are all
probabilistic
you know when do we say that they're
actually different
yup and so the question is is A1
you know A1 equals equals A2 obviously
for this particular symbolic thing it's
going to sit there
but
actually it it it will not so the key
new idea is evaluate those two and
compute A1 minus A2
so the key new idea is that we will
consider two number two arounds equal if
their difference is not significant
meaning there my mu 1 minus mu two plus
one is is smaller than than
the uncertainty
that's it yep
or proportion right so now we can
continue
so we have to worry about these two four
uh functions numerical order equal
same key on order and Min and these are
the proposals
right and basically order and same queue
we don't worry about because I'm not
sure I agree with you on that but we'll
get to that in a minute okay
no wait a minute assigned plus minus one
what does that mean
oh numerical order I I got it I'm sorry
I wasn't reading properly
okay
if the ABS of the difference
why the heck are we doing this
is less than twice the standard
deviation
so yeah I mean I think the idea is
some multiple of the uncertainty is
going to be like a tolerance with which
you compare the centers of these around
objects and so it's like the tolerances
that we use for floating Point
arithmetic equal we allow seven bits of
difference same Q we allow one bit of
difference so I think Jose could
correctly if I'm wrong that's correct
it's it's doing some multiple of the
uncertainty and taking
specific factors one for equal and one
well you're not using a different one
for same q but uh but that's uh that's a
different story thank you for you is
purely structural I guess on these
operators yeah
yeah so so we are imitating what numbers
do here
in the sense of having equal being more
tolerant than numerical order
right
and the question is is two a good
factors so I mean obviously it's going
to need some kind of
well this is like two Sigma is that is
that right is that how I can think about
it exactly yep
there are some plots Below in the
statistical discussion section
right so the key point is what we just
basically said right the difference is
uh you know significantly different from
zero and you know Jose and I are
suggesting we do one Sigma for numerical
order and two Sigma for
uh for you know less or for equal I
guess so two that's that's five percent
is that right what's the what's the
confidence is that 95 confidence
yes
and one would be 68. you know
so these curves were what we were
suggesting the previous time in which
there was no notion of equality it was
always either
f plus one or minus one and now we have
this intermediate region the green
region which is equality
and so you see how now uh greater and
and less do never
overlap
which is good exactly yep
and so this is just a scary I mean this
this thing about having
you know it's a bit arbitrary but of
course it's been arbitrary for years
what we do with finite Precision numbers
and it has to be yeah
it's a judgment called where we put the
boundaries but but now that the new
thing is that there is a region of
equality
and these are the one Sigma two Sigma
three sigma the the red lines
is there any way of um
for our usual tolerance there's no way
of adjusting that as well
yeah nobody's cared in 30 years
uh some people have cared and there are
internal variables that they can
uh you know fiddle with right there's
internal dollar uh equal tolerance I
think and same Q tolerance
Mark you put you're the most likely
person to have run across these kinds of
things I wrote them
okay bye
okay and you know
very there are situations when you need
to adjust the tolerances like in hashing
hashing of numbers you need to have a
zero tolerance otherwise you get like a
floating Point drift of things when
you're doing like counting bins and
stuff like that and then uh if you do
one method using a hashing and one
method without hashing and it all gets
it gets to be a horrible mess it gets to
be method independent with the quadratic
method and the hashing method and
everything so in in any given method you
need to fix the tolerance of things that
you're working on and then you need to
set that kind of is your universe and
then you need to kind of work in that
this stuff here well it's it's a similar
idea to what
um
Jose's and it's I guess are proposing
here I mean it's uh we could argue about
whether the factor of two there or one
or three or whatever is too large or too
small what it should be it doesn't have
to be a whole number it could be
uh like we use one bit which is 0.3
decimal digits the same queue tolerance
of floating numbers
um so I mean but but the concept is very
similar to what we do for floating Point
numbers so I think it's the kind of the
right concept okay fine you just so you
just need to kind of decide which
functions
uh what the tolerance should be and
um that sort of thing okay so but we
have this notion of um oh my God what is
this called system
oh my gosh what are the what are the
system settings low-level system
settings
they're they're internal I I mean their
internal things
usual wrapper for internal system
settings what's it called
system options yeah
yeah I don't want to make it as public
as system options because these really
are things that you should put in a
block so they get reset within a
specific small computation system
options are more things that you set
globally
like the number of threads or something
like you just work with them in your
session but these are very local private
things that you want to do on a very
specific function and you don't think
Visa end user there's you don't think
typically this is this needs to be
unused I mean the difference it's scary
the code is not prepared for everywhere
so that's why
but let me make a point about this with
numbers we have control
you know if you have what happens if you
have high Precision numbers
what happens to this there you have
essentially a very small interval so
very small uncertainty so the
uncertainty is around the LA the the the
the last digit there okay so it's still
a one bit uncertainty is that right we
we do an example of that in the notebook
right uh no but I'm sorry that's what
we're seeing right there right
yeah but Steven's using very high
Precision which is which would be a tiny
tiny interval your your intervals are
almost the size of the number there in
in your examples in the notebook hold on
hold on I'm just trying to understand we
don't do anything different with high
Precision numbers than we do with low
Precision numbers in terms of the last
bit is ignored for comparisons or
whatever else we're doing is that
correct uh that's correct yeah uh well
um
order for example takes into account the
Precision so it will look at uh you know
the more precise one it has a note so
order isn't purely structured and that's
one of the the the the questions I have
for for itai and and Jose so order
the floating Point numbers actually have
some knowledge about the numbers it's
like doing an infinite Precision kind of
comparison uh where it's like
considering all the bits uh and then
it's kind of comparing the scales and
then the precisions of them and stuff
like that to to determine which one
comes before the other so it's not doing
a subtraction but it is doing analysis
of the floating Point number
right but it's based on the center isn't
it Mark of the interval yeah yeah it's
based on the center of the interval
exactly yeah that avoids having a sort
where you have a bunch of things
and and you wind up with the first one
much bigger than the last because yeah
because of drift and with your Precision
I could with your definition I could put
together an example of a list that would
sort in the wrong order because of your
your tolerance and numerical order
yeah that is kind of a problem and
that's another thing with
um it uh with uh Italian and Jose's
proposal their numerical order proposal
is having a non-zero tolerance for the
yeah I think you're proposing one yeah
which kind of is a little bit scary to
me wait wait a minute your point is okay
hold on let me just understand this so
right now
with numbers
we have a comparison Criterion that is
based on a fixed number of bits in a
number of any length
those are allowed to be fuzz is that
correct but not quite but not we have a
comparison function that takes how many
bits to allow when you compare the two
things and that can be zero bits that
means it absolutely needs to take the
entire number and that's what order uses
or it could be numerical order that says
go all the way up to where the interval
of uncertainty starts uh that's like a
kind of uh zero tolerance
uh sorry order would be like minus
infinity or something like that and then
we have equal that has like seven bits
it allows like seven bits of the of the
number to be different so like a
Precision of two When you subtract them
it will allow numbers that are close to
each other too okay so so it's seven
bits still here even though this is many
more bits
when you do equals equals yeah that's
yeah that's correct but it's seven bits
in the difference of of the uh of the of
the two numbers that you're saying so if
I if I do this to Power 60 so this is um
Plus
10 to the minus sixty
times
seven bits is I don't know what you know
let's say 32. uh long two of uh uh
there's two of ten times 60 or something
like that it's
percent 409 equals equals
410.
yeah I see
okay
yeah and if you make that like a little
bit more there I mean you might be just
on the boundary with 32 so so you know
you make it like 128 or something then
it should be different yeah
right and I guess finite Precision
numbers suffer from equality being
not necessarily transitive
yes that's right which
you know and that's a problem
you know which our proposal also suffers
from but I don't see a way around it
yeah
yeah but I mean explain why you want
numerical order to be fuzzy
for these versus the way it is for
numbers
well I guess yeah because not numbers
it's a zero tolerance it's not true look
at the example on the left what it says
10 1 and
10.11 and those are still considered
equal in numerical order
because when you that that 0.1 is an
insignificant bit so when you subtract
them you've got a tiny tiny Precision
there Jose that that's the thing your
interval is so wide in that number that
it's effectively only one digit
but but the number still remembers the
10.1 so the input form of that number
still remembers
so I think there is some tolerance if
you take x minus y there of that 10
Factor one and Y 10.1 back to the back
to one if you do x minus y you'll get a
an input form of that you'll get a zero
yeah if you look at the input form of
that
yes but but the input form of of Y is
still remembering the point one if I
remember correctly
yeah but but
so in a sense
something is ignoring that that point
one
God this is weird I mean welcome to
floating Point arithmetic but yeah if we
if we want to have numerical order with
no tolerance with around that's also
fine with me I mean the
the thing is is to have this some sort
of choice of the levels of Tolerance
that we have we want for these functions
right and yeah right and
I mean
personally I think it's quite weird if
this well I guess part of the question
is what do we do about men and right and
I I think but but Maine will just be
based off the choice that you use in the
American order that's all it will do it
will just take whatever the result of
the numerical order is if it's one minus
one or zero and it will do that or
either swap them or give you the first
one or whatever so Min is just a
consequence of numerical order I think
yeah so let me just understand your the
the point of contention so we are
agreeing that equal is okay we don't
know if this two is the right number but
but it might yeah yeah maybe okay all
right so we're agreed on that so the
question that remains is numerical order
mm-hmm
and
the argument that's being made is the
numerical order Criterion here
which is
wait a minute is this the right way
around or should that be a half for 95
confidence
if the difference of the means
surely that should be a half there no
that one no no no because if you have
two things that differ by a little bit
right they're equal
I'm sorry I'm confused this thing is
less than
this thing is saying
this quantity X
right we're saying that we that then
it's the you know right
um then if this is great right if that
quantity is greater than two Sigma then
there's a 95 probability that that
difference is not equal to zero
oh I see
I see okay yeah I get it I get it I get
it I get it
so it's like the
well that thing on the left is getting
really big that's when it
right that's when we can just say oh we
we base it based on the centers because
the probability that they're actually
swapped because these are gaussian
distributions is negligible yep okay
okay so the thing at issue is a
numerical order case
okay so what are the arguments and and
so what is Mark what are you arguing for
in that case I mean we in the arbitrary
Precision code use zero as the tolerance
so when you subtract the numbers you
must get a floating point zero
yeah but I'm actually looking at a mark
numerical order is different than order
for this yeah yeah your order is going
to use even all the insignificant bits
minus infinite precision
so uh the American order is gonna in the
American order does this it exposes a
few hidden bits does the subtraction and
then fiddles around uh and checks if the
Precision of that thing is going to be
zero or not and and checks if it's going
to be uh
zero test
is analogous to the comparison of the
with the standard deviation is it not
yes yes
but it's with zero but with zero
tolerance right
well yeah right because you have hard
borders right yeah
I look at this directly now because I
mean if I say Precision P I'm losing P
bits of precision that means I have 2 to
the minus p
you know if I'm
what is I I'm not correctly seeing the
math of this but I mean basically you're
saying it's a box whose size is
determined by the Precision
the you know to if the if the bits
falling off the end of the Precision
thing uh if it's Precision P any bit
that is yeah it's 2 to the minus P isn't
it that the box is a width two to the
minus P give or take if we're using p
bets
if you're using if the number is
accurately a Precision P then nothing
smaller than that Precision any bits
beyond the piece bit
are undetermined therefore the size of
the box of indeterminacy is 2 to the
minus p
right well I'm just pointing out that
when when normally when we say
P you know Precision P we mean p decimal
digits so that's why I'm being done when
you're saying P if the Precision is p
bits then yeah yeah but I mean
internally it's all bits so Stephen is
just thinking like close to the computer
which is how it's actually implemented
hard borders two to the minus P so what
you're saying is numerical order
if it is not within those hard borders
if it is within the hard border it
thinks it's equal if it's outside the
hard border then it does its you know
whatever ordering it's doing right yeah
okay so the question is what is the
analog of the hard Border in the case of
a round and the problem is around
doesn't have a hard border because guess
what it looks like this you know it's
gaussians
right so what do we do you know in the
case in radical order we you know these
things will be will be step functions
um
and you know I have to say I think it's
reasonable if I'm not being confused
somehow it thinks it's reasonable to use
a Criterion like this in the case where
because there is no hard border now the
question is yeah what what what yeah the
question is what is the constant in
front of that square root that's the
question I know okay fine okay so so I'm
fine with decreasing it I'm having a
half or something like that
to be more strict
which means that you have to be in a
closer
right in order to make
go ahead you're right that that you know
the probability of overlap is even even
greater
than
right so the centers are much you know
that much closer than the standard
deviation so right there's
you real you know at that right at that
point the probability that you quote
unquote have the wrong
uh
well let's compute those probabilities
it's just an earth of some kind right
right
so what is the actual function of
um
well this isn't the same as like the
student T distribution or something is
that what you're doing that's different
no no
right I mean we have that computation in
in in in the statistical discussion
section right right there Earth Earthsea
okay
yes and it's interesting to see that
that quotient that we have been looking
at appears there naturally
the two times this two times the
difference divided by the square root of
the sums
the two
the elements of of the subtraction of
the two arounds
Center and standard deviation I get it I
get it but I mean okay so that's the ABS
but now there's a square root of two
here
which we could presumably take out of
the earth could we know I don't remember
the
relations for Earth
it's not like an exponential where we
can trade it out
but that's square root of two
okay so if we if we take this
we're asking the question as you change
that number
I'm I'm pretty confused I think you
should look at the plots
the plots at the bottom
right and that one right there I think
is the most helpful right so you know
the the blue area is uh
the
um I I think it I think the three at the
bottom are clearer the ones for one
Sigma two Sigma three sigma okay yeah
yeah no no further than
this string so for example if we have
the two first gaussians do we consider
that those are clearly separated though
that's the meaning of one Sigma and and
for example we might say there is a lot
of overlapping but if you think the the
center of the yellowish distribution is
clearly
at the at the tail of the blue
okay you know what this reminds me of it
reminds me of like the error Criterion
and diffraction
right yeah so right so why why you know
that's a function right there that you
can right so why don't we plot one half
Sigma and and and see what that looks
like
one half Sigma being what you are
proposing if you had a one-half instead
of a one this is this is what you're
currently proposing for
um Okay can somebody
whoops
[Music]
defined sorry
didn't realize we had that extra input
there
remind me what the area Criterion is
it's the first minimum you know what I'm
saying you you guys remember this and
diffraction right the 1.22 Lambda over D
business yep right so that the area
correct you're in is that the first
minimum of the diffraction Peak
that you are
I mean maybe it's different because it's
a question of what you visually perceive
there so it's a different type of thing
but this is the same kind of question I
think
right I mean it's it's it's it's it's
it's given given a what you know a
wavelength Lambda what's you know the
smallest
uh
you know area you can resolve based on
the instruction pattern right
or or length scale you can resolve not
there yet but
okay so listen let's understand what
you're saying here so you're saying the
Criterion is in this case here the two
Sigma case
is the case where those two things are
considered equal
as soon as they are closer than this is
that correct that's the equal right
exactly so those suggestions will be
that's the border of separation between
being separated
and it's quite fun already
you really think it's okay to consider
them equal when they're that far apart
yeah and that kind of worries me too so
so that's why I'm saying two equal to
Sigma may be already very tolerant
exactly yeah yes
I mean equals sometimes feel a bit too
tolerant but but okay so one Criterion
is
you know you see that little dip there
for what
you know this is like are you a bimodal
distribution or is it all smooshed
together
for what Sigma
I mean and clearly that's going to
depend on the width of this thing here
yeah
I kind of think that this if this is all
a smoosh distribution it never goes down
of course we're not seeing the sum of
the distributions here
that's a very arbitrary Criterion I mean
there is a we could try if you're with
the formulas but there's the formula for
you know what's basically the p-value
that the means are different given the
two you know means yeah that I think is
the student T distribution is it not
well right when you have a small sample
size you use the key distribution but if
you have a lot of samples I think
there's just a formula given the means
the standard deviations of the normal
distributions
and we do we're effectively assuming
infinite number of samples in this case
we're assuming we actually have the
distribution
right the sample number doesn't enter
into it right so you're suggesting
in the shocking kind of you're
suggesting a p-value Criterion
yeah maybe I mean I think it's better
than something arbitrary like just how
the plots line up with each other right
and then right then these plots are a
little misleading right because exactly
how much they look like they overlap
depends on the particular Sigma 1 and
sigma 2 chosen
all right well so what p-value assume
that we can do this with p-values which
we can clearly do right what p-value
what probability of the means and fact
being different
would you want to take
for the case of equal
would you be satisfied would you
consider them if the probability that
the means are right and right and so so
my objection to one Sigma is all right
so you're going to say that this is less
than this when there's in fact a 32
percent chance that these numbers are
equal
right that you know if you draw an
infinite number of times 32 percent of
the time the the values will be
you know reversed essentially
um
okay hold on hold on
okay
the question is given these two
distributions
what's the probability that the true
mean
let's see the the well you're asking for
reversal but I'm I'm just saying
the probability that the true means are
equal
is not something you can compute because
that's a point thing from a continuous
distribution is it not right you know I
don't know what you mean by the two
means are equal right I mean we know
what the means are and they're not equal
given that we know the distributions
exactly yeah yeah right right the
correct question is given okay
Turin I mean this is why we started out
by Computing the probability you know
given you know our mu one our our mu one
which we took to be zero and our mu two
that we call to be mu what's the
probability that you know X1 is less
than X2
okay
um and then then we right and then on
our live stream suggests that we look at
this thing here
receiver operating characteristic
I've never heard of this thing we're
talking about
binary class first was discrimination
threshold was varied this does seem
relevant
I mean we can we can study more
probabilistic
characteristics of this problem but I
think we just need some sort of
judgment call to make this work
right and then if we have to adapt it in
the future a bit to change the
confidence levels we can but
this seems relevant thank you for the
suggestion here
I think this is relevant oh look at this
this type of approach would require a
new function in which we can specify in
a separate argument
the level of confidence that we want or
P levels or whatever but
I think we want something automatic
no I agree I agree I agree
what is this whole thing
we have a setting like we have for equal
tolerance and same here tolerance which
is hidden but could be set on a block
that would be the no I understand but
that's a that's an escape valve well
sure sure of course it is but yeah but
let's look at this receiver operating
characteristic which I have never heard
of
oh yeah we will
um
all right but we're going to pick two
numbers and they're somewhere between a
half and two probably and that will be
our default and we can have an escape
valve and
I think that's where we should go and
around around is still experimental
correct
it is yes right and so yes and and you
know
which right I just mean I I was just
saying you know
we could maybe make the the Escape
valves perhaps slightly lessen or or
just sort of tell us let's make them
hidden I don't think they're ever going
to be relevant that's just you know well
I'm just I'm just thinking if we get
feedback it's too strict it's not strict
enough then you know it might be useful
for people to be able to tweak but
um I see this the thing that's
interesting here
in this course this is you know false
positive rate false negative rate
true positive true negative
so that's a way of characterizing
if you've got these two distributions
right it's the Criterion this will be
our
false negative rate
is our rate of thinking they're the
wrong way around so to speak is our rate
of of having the the the the variables
assigned the wrong way round
Etc
that makes sense
the um
[Music]
right I I'm not sure we ever heard
or or maybe I just missed it you know
Mark's objection to to Saint cue yeah no
save queue is fine it's just structural
but I was worried about orders so you
talked about in numerical order that's
numerical values but what how does order
sort around objects
well I think if it doesn't take it
by sentence by centers and then using
the true order on the numbers
yeah but that is like numerical order
but that's like with an infinite uh or
using all you know ignoring the
uncertainties exactly exactly yeah okay
that's absolutely fine that's exactly
what I think it should do yeah okay
right exactly so yeah no I do I just
thought it didn't take a no I did yeah
so it is kind of related it's like
having the constant zero in your in your
uh in your uh
are already doing the right thing here
because of the structure because having
the center as first argument
yeah all right yeah we can do collab
actually here okay do we want to talk uh
a bit at all about the anti-symmetric
case Oh you mean the asymmetric case uh
yes asymmetric case yes yes
right which our proposal is basically to
do the same thing only
you know we first uh you know compare
the centers to decide which which Sigma
faces the other and use those is the
basic idea
in the asymmetric case the distribution
is broken into two pieces is that
correct correct yeah
yes it is
the the distribution of one asymmetric
around is is uh you know is two half
gaussians right right which uh it's a
discontinuous as a function of of uh you
know variable value it's a discontinuous
p of X is discontinuous in x right
I mean one could have a discussion of is
that the right
model but that is the model we are
currently using yeah that's the model
we're using
I think I think any other model
I mean you know you're chasing
you know the whole points are around is
you've got some rough estimate of how
much error there is in something
and you know by the time you're saying
well actually it's this particular you
know asymmetric distribution well then
you're using completely different
technology
yep
okay so you're saying look at the facing
sigmas so to speak
and then apply this criteria
right which means that
I mean other
sort of paradoxical cases where you have
a very very wimpy
you know opposing Sigma
in which yes exactly right so you you
can have a case where you know what the
center that is higher has a probability
of being you know asymptotically
approached three quarters of being less
than the lower Center
this case for example we consider them
equal because the overlapping is large
the the long tails are facing precisely
each other
so they overlap a lot this criteria
would say that these two are equal
while if you face them the other way
further down they are different ah
because they overlap very little and so
that side is
is very precise in a sense oh boy
well I mean in that
receiver operating characteristic thing
for example what matters that you know
it seems
this is the whole question about what's
the area of overlap
right seems to be the Thing Worth
thinking about which is an integral
which means that that number isn't a
pure ratio of standard deviation to
difference of means
it's some inverse earth type thing about
I would have thought that the
you know the Criterion should be
something about the size of the overlap
integral as compared to the size of the
non-overlapping parts
which is essentially what we're
simplifying by I mean so right in the
symmetric case that's basically what
we're doing exactly right we're just you
know using a multiple of the standard
deviation as opposed to and here yes
we're cheating a little but it's not I
you know what is your proposal here for
touch you do
right so we take the two centers and and
order them as if they were exact or you
know whatever Precision numbers they are
and then we you know use that to
determine which of the plus or minus is
facing the other Center and use that in
the standard DB to compute an effective
standard deviation and then use the
symmetric Criterion
and then in the top place where the
large standard deviations are facing
each other
right we see a large area you know
there's a large area where they can be
oppositely ordered and we declare them
to be equal because they're both sort of
near the middle I understand why the
Criterion isn't if the overlap area
divided by total area
is greater than blah
then they're considered equal if the
overlap area is less than blah you know
let's say the overlap area is 95. well
let's first of all Define overlap area
but it's going to in the end it's going
to be similar it's just that we want a
Criterion which is fast enough to be
computed
this this
okay so you have to approximate that but
I mean if what we're thinking about is
what's the probability that there is
we're looking at the negation right or
our equality function right is one minus
the probability that you know one guy is
less than the other mine and minus the
other other way
and we're looking at when is that large
uh-huh
so we can test your idea I think it's
going to end up being something very
similar but fine I I'm sure it is too
I'm sure you can approximate it very
well by some purely arithmetic Criterion
so to speak that doesn't involve Earths
and so on
uh but I mean you know assuming it was
an integral Criterion what would we want
the ratio in order for the things to be
declared equal what do we want the
overlap probability to be
I would say very similar numbers to the
ones we use for the symmetric case which
is what 90 95 percent
yes if we are using like one half and
one
Sigma what happens
what we were using before yeah two
segments okay so final question then
numerical order as compared to a quality
test same Criterion or different
criteria
I would say numerical order has some
Sigma multiple which is smaller than one
I would say one half seven
okay three quarters of Sigma
all right let's just see what this means
for the overlap and it goes and then I
think we're done
okay can we move on yep okay
all right bra and Cat
so this is I mean something we discussed
possibly pre-pandemic it took so long
for somebody to to go and do this but uh
it's uh you know so now we're just
talking about the documentation
BP as opposed to AP before pandemic no
no we didn't have an AP by the way
um
okay so the only question here is
whether it's bear logs or whether it's a
list
and it wants to be a list which is
why does it want to be the list because
it because when you put a brand together
that has to have be too hard
for consistency with braquette
I see
that does make sense yeah do we have
anybody here representing the quantum
framework
is this going to be is the kind of phone
we're going to use this directly
I don't think we have anybody
representing the quantum framework
okay well can somebody check with them I
mean it looks okay to me assuming
they're happy with it
okay
yep we can check with them
okay let's go Echo here
right so I mean this is you know a big
messy discussion so I don't know that we
well let's give it a try for a minute
okay
what we've talked about previously is
let's see where did we get to last time
uh
uh didn't didn't we already have a
discussion okay well we we had a
five-minute discussion at the end of uh
okay all right okay okay okay okay so
so let's let's describe what some of the
things we think we want are
goals
okay
um
so
uh
you know put
a wrapper around the whole evaluation
to
sort of penalize slash limit slash
whatever Echoes within it
that's one type of thing
another thing we want
is for a single Echo
make it not
generate
too much stuff
or
penalize itself
is that a fair
wow concept
I I thought we had shelved that idea
okay well tell me where we've got to
before
well I you know there there's the list
of the functions that were discussed in
in the last time we had a serious
discussion
and you know I'm not sure we're we're
going to you know page in and and move
beyond that in in the few minutes that
are left
um but uh well okay so you're suggesting
that we table this for a custom Echo
discussion basically sure
uh what else do we need to prepare for
that discussion do we think we have the
use cases understood
well I I mean there were uh
uh well it's not clear to me that we
have the use cases understood
um
and that's what I was trying to write
down what some of the use cases are I
mean the basic point is
you're trying to balance the number I
mean it's essentially
um
okay and Echo is being used
as a
as a diagnostic but once you've seen it
a few times it's enough
you don't want to I mean the cases where
I've literally had the thing running
that's generated a you know 100 megabyte
notebook just echoing random stuff out
when I didn't know it was ever going to
trigger right I was just that like is it
going to trigger or not
you see what I'm asking
but what you don't really want it you
know
okay you're asking the question does it
trigger okay you see five five triggers
five you know actions of it
that's presumably you know then that's
enough you don't want to see it a
hundred thousand times
that's one use case what's that well I
mean I would agree you don't want to see
it a hundred thousand times but I I
disagree that the lower limit is five I
mean for what if I'm when I'm actually
debugging these things it can easily be
dozens fine fine okay the question is
okay what's the Criterion
what's what is the Criterion to shut it
up
okay
so a
you've seen it
more than x times
B you've seen
more than x Echoes altogether
in this input line what's another
Criterion
right and and you're you're imagining
something where just all you have is
Echo and there's no outer wrapper
no I'm I'm saying we could put an auto
wrapper around the whole thing to
determine this the issue is okay so you
know for example we could have you know
an echo
okay
Echo control
right of expert
and maybe we have something where we can
say we can put an echo control there
that has a nice sub-value where you say
Echo control and you say
five or something and that means I don't
know what that's per thing or whether
that's you know maybe this means that's
the maximum per thing and then this is
the maximum total and things like this
right
all right I mean so I right I you'll
notice that I have a suggestion of using
Echo uh Echo quiet
um
the same way there right in the middle
okay yeah but of course you would right
we would need to implement you know
actually Implement hold all sub values
before something like this could work
um
I see right otherwise all the Echoes
would evaluate before the quiet Echo
yeah okay fine but we could do the case
of this without sub values without
solving that problem
uh sure
um
but sub-value case is more useful but
okay the case is the okay again again
another another goal is
um some evaluation produces lots of
Echoes
when it's finished get rid of them
that's Echo cleanup or cleanup Echo
yep
um
I don't think you're I don't think any
of this is significantly different from
what we discussed last time yeah I agree
I agree we need to hone in on what we
really want to do but okay down on a
live stream is suggesting what about
redirecting Echoes to a different window
or file
yeah so and one of the things I was
gonna ask not being an echo expert is uh
so Echo has the side effect of creating
a thing in the front end potentially
does it have any other side effects
no
because and the reason I ask is because
managing a stream of Echoes
looks a lot like a log file
sure and
what one of the things that makes log
files useful is being able to uh process
them symbolically
lots of interesting points
um I mean you know how
how do people process a log file that is
hundreds of megabytes you know they're
doing things like uh filter by time
filter by the name of the event filter
by you know some other criteria that is
being symbolically collected uh you know
and and then show me only the relevant
stuff uh
kinds of things
kind of yeah
so I mean that you know you could
imagine something that says reap Echo
and so you know I mean maybe sometimes
you know
it's maybe you kind of want to see the
100 megabyte stuff because
because it's going to take some
exploration to figure out what the
relevant portion of it is and I when I
say see it I don't mean literally embed
it in the notebook I mean but have it
available to you for exploration
right I mean this is okay the other
another case is redirect The Echoes
somewhere else
like print action
yes
which we don't have Freckle right
we do not
right that was another suggestion that I
thought we had tabled in favor of the
list that we had at the top here
well okay you're telling me basically we
can't solve a problem right now
but well I really think this is the
thing we should you know we need to
address it's a very useful piece of
functionality but yes well right there
are details we need to get into and each
time I bring this up you get distracted
by this grandiose vision and never
discuss the details so okay example of
detail
uh well like uh this uh
um dollar Echo limit I I don't know
um
right you know a a the name is wrong B
I'm not sure what it is we were actually
you know what it is we want to apply
here and and how we get there from here
so
this is a more complicated discussion
you're right we we we kind of run out of
time here so probably we should wrap
this now and expect to do a custom
meeting just about Echo
for a change
it's just that the the around stuff what
what you know since we could foresee
getting around stuff done for 13-3 that
took precedence fun
okay sounds good anything else for here
right now nope
okay see you all soon thanks to folks on
the live stream some good suggestions
there much appreciated
see you all soon